in two weeks your caucus is going to
decide who's going to be the next
chairman would you like to be the next
chairman of ways and means
i would it will be it is my intention to
seek that now that the election has had
i feel comfortable saying such things um
dave still has two months to go we've
got things to do in the lame duck with
respect to what we call tax extenders
i'll be supporting him as our chairman
in completing that legislation but i
will be seeking on that seat and if you
are if you become ways and means
committee chairman uh does that mean you
could not run for president
oh al i'll think about that stuff in
2015. right now i'm just focused on here
in the now and tonight i'll worry about
all those things later